hi friends welcome back we are making
some changes around here first and
foremost
this channel is now going to be called
chris williamson not
modern wisdom modern wisdom isn't going
anywhere the podcast is still
my baby and me and video guy dean will
continue to deliver you the most
interesting humans that we can find
as often as we can get the episodes out
but
i don't just want to do podcasts i want
to
do down the pipe monologue videos like
this originally
when i launched the channel i didn't
really think i had anything to say and i
still
maybe don't but it would appear that
there is an audience
out there for the sort of topics that we
talk about and
i have my own inputs as well i love
being
a stage for the guests to come on to
i want them to feel like this is an
environment in which they can be their
best
and give you the insight that it's taken
them an entire career to come up with
but i want to say my stuff too and that
means that i need to
first off get comfortable on camera by
doing more of this stuff
and also pivot outside of just the
podcast so yes
this channel is now chris williamson you
will get all of the same modern wisdom
loveliness that you always have
but you will also get more videos like
this
more of me doing deep dives into purpose
or meaning
or depression or fitness or productivity
or finances
or whatever it is that i've learned this
week some of you may be
subscribed to my newsletter link in
comments below
and a lot of the stuff that i talk about
on there i never get to really discuss
on the podcast more personal stuff
insights from my own life
and experiences that i've gone through
in the past
that sometimes illuminate and add a lot
of context to what we're talking about
so yeah if there's something that you
want to see me talk about
just throw it in the comments below i'm
more than happy to do deep dives into
any of these things i find it really
therapeutic to talk about this stuff on
camera
and hopefully it adds value to yourself
as well
i'm really really grateful for this
project i've never felt
more connected to anything that i've
done in my life
ever and i wanted to thank you for being
a part of this it really is very
meaningful to me
it provides more meaning than pretty
much anything else that i've ever done
i often make the joke that my business
partner has two children
and instead of starting a family i just
decided to start a podcast
but i kind of have created a family out
of this i've met some of my best friends
i've made relationships and friendships
that i can
see lasting a lifetime all through this
weaponized curiosity so thank you for
being a part of it
hopefully the growth and the insights
and the learning and
everything continues to go the way it is
it makes me very very happy
and i hope it does you as well so that's
it not much
is going to change other than more of
the conversations that you
love to listen to and that i love to be
a part of let me know what you think in
the comments below
and i'll see you in the next episode
peace
[Music]
you